les 9 heures ce mercredi 9 mars la team
78 s'est donné rendez vous dans cette
exploitation yvelinoise pour une journée
du champ à l'assiette organisait avec le
département objectif pour les
producteurs locaux faire découvrir leurs
produits aux influences euse relais du
département ne s'était pas la fapa de
notre aventure dans la production de
grandes cultures à destination du local
des yvelines et tout particulièrement
des collèges est divine c'est un no tsy
boxer très bien de multiplier des axes
de communication puis c'est chouette
d'avoir un peu finalement le l'envers du
décor de ce comptable dans l'assiette il
nous a expliqué tous qui plantait
différemment même des choses donc voilà
on n'imaginerait pas que ça puisse
pousser dans les yvelines au programme
de la journée cuisine et ses produits
locaux direction le collège et les
volières aux essarts-le-roi pour mettre
la main à la pâte mais avant cela il
faut s'équiper
l'équipement la charlotte qui va bien et
on va avoir une petite toque à notre nom
et justement c'est intéressant c'est de
voir comment on peut intégrer des choses
local bas à des grosses quantités de
cantine c'est là aussi où finalement il
y en a peut-être le plus besoin parce
que c'est nos enfances et voilà c'est
eux qui aussi ont besoin le plus de bien
manger la team 78 est répartie en
plusieurs binômes un travail d'équipé
pour décliner la lentille sous toutes
ses formes
elle a commencé notre côté moi je fais
un peu la season quand je commence ma
raisonnement
et puis comme ça après on va faire ça à
toutes les deux bon voilà on va faire
une bonne petite entrée concert verra
dans des verrines faire déjà toutes ses
couleurs et malgré le mal que j'ai
toutes les senteurs et ultra pétition au
menu ce tabou les deux pattes vers l'est
avec l'entier de corail les lentilles
vertes avec filet de saumon et en
dessert des cupcakes pomme chocolat à
base de farine de lentilles est on en
train de dresser les cas grec est donc
dans les préparations chocolat
sucré aux pommes caramélisées que des
choses délicieuses quoi au combat et le
cas devient aussi hélas apprendre à
faire cuire et ita fort à faire avec les
coaches à double la décoration sur le
dessus un avant-goût de légumes quoi
c'est vraiment ça va ça donne un superbe
ou au dessert même dans le sucré et
c'est génial de le savoir parce qu'on a
forcément le réflexe normal de prendre
la farine de blé est classique et là ça
change c'est un très bon goût et une
kate monde à aimer vraiment en même
temps pas question d'oublier leur
mission expliquer le cheminement des
produits du producteur au consommateur
surtout et qu'ils comprennent que
vraiment le circuit de ce qu'on a fait
ce matin qu'il va être là dans les
assiettes de recul symétrique
un menu élaboré pour une quarantaine de
couverts et pour la préparation elles
peuvent compter sur les conseils avisés
de la chef
notre coriande weiss
je jouais le rôle du malade du manager
fait qu'ils étaient là en train de
donner des directives aux influences
euse qui ont joué le jeu et qui ont été
vraiment très présent tout au long de la
journée
[Musique]
après l'effort le réconfort place à la
dégustation
élèves professeurs et personnels
administratifs étaient au rendez vous
ils se sont régalés
non non je suis la chaise vide h f mais
vous pouvez vous amuser du coup à la
maison moi j'essaie de bien mélanger les
couleurs parce que quand c'est joli ça
donne la vie d'avant mais il ya des
recettes tout facile à faire à la maison
c'est rigolo quoi visiblement c'est très
bon j'avais envie de voir parce que
c'est des saveurs un peu particulier
pour les enfants il ya un peu de gens
mais il ya du poivron il ya l'oignon
rouge il ya un préjugé des a priori sur
deux sur les lentilles il segal
mélenchon n'a pas vraiment
à palerme en tenant la décla sociétaux
sahel c'est différent on apprend qu'ils
n'aiment pas les lentilles mais c'est
bien on sent qu'on sent pas le tout les
gens si
c'est pas une forme habituelle les
lentilles corail en plus moi j'en
consomme pas forcément très
régulièrement et puis le mélange avec
les petites pattes la ouais pas mal le
saumon avec les petits légumes dessus
vraiment très goûteux mission accomplie
pour les influences euse les recettes
pourraient être intégrées au menu
l'année prochaine